other top homeland security official
exits as officials worry about a punch
we've seen staffing purges before but
the pace of this current one feels a
little bit different this near systemic
purge in the Department of Homeland
Homeland Security are we now beginning
to see him act out in the form of
purging and mass firing and completely
not listening to any logic it's a purge
they say so when people aren't getting
the job done you just leave him in for
as long as possible only in Washington
would that be a montage we could put
together imagine doing that in the
business world Donald Trump is making a
number of moves as it relates to the
department of homeland security and not
a moment too soon
Kristin Nielsen is out as DHS head this
comes just days after the president
withdrew Ronald Vagelos name from
consideration to be director of ice
Secret Service Director Randolph tech
sales is being removed after a number of
embarrassing stories came out about lack
Secret Service procedures especially at
mar-a-lago and late today rumors began
to circulate that Francis Cissna
director of you CIS was also on his way
out though that has not been confirmed
and some immigration hardliners are
calling for him to be spared joining me
now with reaction former acting director
of ice Tom Holman so what about all
these personnel moves look I think the
president they all serve at the pleasure
of the president and I think he's
frustrated at what's going on right now
and he's looking to go in a different
direction as he said a tougher direction
I am personally been involved in any of
these decisions of course I'm on the
outside but I think all three of them I
think they deserve some respect they did
serve their nation that difficult jobs
add half a Congress don't like them
half a congress don't support what
they're doing but you have a tough you
have a tough skin you have a very thick
skin
most people wilt under the pressure I
mean Donald Trump's the only guy who
could have withstood this in Russia but
think about it your your sis now you're
head of that you see is meaning
underneath you they do all the credible
fear screenings people coming into the
country from Central America they state
a credible fear they're just released
into this system at 714 days sir they're
out there you know a lot of me never see
again there are a lot of things that
they could do at UCA is
to re-examine the way that credible fear
screening is done which is completely
comforts with the law the State
Department what they think of various
parts of El Salvador Honduras whether
there'd ain't really dangerous
or whether this is just a script being
used none of that was done so well
they're all these hard liners out there
going this guy sits none I don't know
him but oh well he's the greatest thing
since sliced bread the problem is things
aren't getting done and Beyond Congress
and Congress has to act there are
federal things that can be done
executive branch and agency level
actions that can be taken but you got to
have a strong constitution to do that
even if you agree with the president and
all the underlying issues you know I
think there's some things gonna be done
I talked about you so many times things
I can do maybe some more things we can
do within the government oh well I had
mine out paid months when I was in I've
been in many meetings with all these
folks and I actually thought Frances was
doing a good job at what he had at the
time I think so just like the secretary
said I I think the law strangles them
sometimes so everything on credible fear
they can do a lot more I'm not a
credible for expert I just always
percent fraud I'm more the new head of
DHS deserves his team acting head
McAllen in Hindi he deserves his own
team beneath him but it this is a crisis
I like the fact that the president makes
a change it's not working
clearly we got a team in a place that
has to execute and get the job done
I think Kevin Mack Elaine is a good
choice I've worked with Kevin
shoulder-to-shoulder last few years we
work together under underneath jeh
Johnson when the first crisis happened
all right so crummy way Kevin can hit
the ground running he knows the border
issues has great relationship with many
and he'll he has a great relationship of
the government Mexico Department of
Defense so I think he can I think he can
get some things done I really do and by
the way another federal judge Ninth
Circuit district court judge ruled
against the administration today another
injunction goes into effect maybe on
Friday administration can't deport
people to Mexico or send people to
Mexico pending their asylum applications
which under federal law is allowed we
now have judges that are a permanent
part of the anti-trump resistance well
two things the Ninth Circuit so you know
President Trump had his argument the
Chief Justice that Ninth Circuit
it wasn't obviously it is and second
thing is look how we surprise these
people if they're escaping fear and
persecution from Honduras Guatemala El
Salvador
during Mexico they have escaped that
fear and persecution so they should be
ok that's why they shouldn't go they can
go to Mexico under federal absolutely
that judge is a complete outrage and
Obama appointee Tom thanks great to see
you